1868 in Spain has just had a revolution
they saw Queen Isabella the second
overthrown and replaced with no one for
now instead the Spanish looked abroad
for a new monarch and the best candidate
was a man could Leopold the Prince of
Hohenzollern Hohenzollern is here by the
way Leopold didn't really want the
throne but was coerced into formally
considering the claim in 1870 by a
certain Otto von Bismarck the Chancellor
of the North German Confederation which
was mostly just Prussia whose king was
william the first of the House of
Hohenzollern
there was one issue with Leopold except
in the Spanish throne France under
Emperor Napoleon the third who wasn't
okay with the Hohenzollern controlling
Spain for France being encircled by a
friendly German Spanish alliance was not
something they wanted to deal with again
that is and so Napoleon wouldn't
tolerate Leopold pushing his claim
Napoleon sent his ambassador to meet the
Prussian King at bad ends William summer
retreat to demand that he would one no
longer Bank Leopold's claim which
William could accept and two he would
never back any Hohenzollern claim to the
Spanish throne ever again which of
course William could never do and so he
said no Bismarck then leaked a slightly
edited telegram of William's refusal
known as the m's telegram to the press
which made it sound what the king had
simply told the French to mind their own
business to the French this insult was
too much in Napoleon decided to preempt
public outrage and ordered the
mobilisation of the French army soon
after this the French parliament voted
to declare war in the North German
Confederation the franco-prussian war
had begun for the southern independent
German states Bavaria württemberg and
Baden the way that William had appeared
to have been treated by the French was
too much along with the fact that the
French declaration of war over an insult
made it seem like there wasn't much
stopping the French from invading if
they felt like it as such curbing French
aggression required the southern German
states to ally with the North German
Confederation so France had a large
well-equipped army based around a corps
of professionals that's not to say the
Prussians were necessarily at a
disadvantage their army was of a similar
size was also well equipped and
contained many veterans
it was the generally superior Prussian
general ship like that of helmet von
moltke which saw France on the backfoot
that combined with Prussia's greater use
of railways to move troops and supplies
to the front lines but the pressure
could bring its full force to bear much
quicker the German Allies won their
first victory at the Battle of vism Berg
on August the 4th which opened the way
to further advances into France over the
next month the French would suffer a
series of defeats until Emperor Napoleon
met the Prussians at the Battle of sedan
this battle did not
go to work with the French and Napoleon
along with over 100,000 men were
defeated and forced to surrender once
news of his surrender reached the
Capitol there were riots and a
revolution which saw the proclamation of
a republic because it was 19th century
Paris and that was what Paris did then
after this the French army basically
disintegrated in the German allies then
took the fortresses of Strasbourg and
Metz and soon after laid siege to Paris
the people of Paris refused to allow the
Allies in and so dug in to resist the
siege was absolutely brutal on the
population and starvation and disease
took a tremendous toll the new leader of
the French Republic adult here was
tasked with negotiating a peace with the
Prussians who weren't the Prussians
anymore since in January 1871 the German
allies had proclaimed the new German
Empire a ceasefire was agreed in
February and after a small revolution in
Paris had to be crushed the Paris
Commune both nations signed the Treaty
of Frankfurt in May of 1871 the treaty
saw the Germans continue to occupy parts
of France until a large war indemnity
was paid the French also agreed to
recognize the new German Empire and of
course Germany would annex the territory
of Alsace Lorraine
or should I say else a slithering in the
franco-prussian war was now over and it
had absolutely colossal implications for
history it saw the unification of the
German Empire which fundamentally
shifted the balance of power in Europe
the annexation of Alsace Lorraine would
dominate French politics for the next
four decades and guarantee French
hostility to Germany I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
a special thanks to James Bissonnette
ozark a flash Henry Robin Winston Cawood
Adam Harvey and Skye Chappell
you